[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره افادت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه بان زلزالين بقوه 6 درجات واربعه
من عشره وخمسه درجات وثمانيه من عشره على
مقياس ريختار ضربا مركز منطقتي دفنه و 18
فيها البلاد مساء امس الاثنين واضاف
الاداره الكوارث انه تم تسجيله اثنتين
وثلاثين هزه ارتداديه بعد الزلزالين
واضافت ان سكان مدنها تاي وغاز عنتاب
ومرسين
وانطاليا وكرما مرشرو بالزلزال وقد شعر
سكان الشمال السوري ولبنان والاردن
وفلسطين بالزلزالين
وقال وزير الداخليه تركيز سليمان صويلو ان
ثلاثه مواطنين لقوا مصرعهم واصيبه
213 جراء الزلزلين اللذين ضربان مركز
منطقتي دفنه وسمندخ في ولايتها الجنوبيه
البلاد واكد الوزير ان اعمال البحث
والانقاذ جاريه في ثلاث مناطق مختلفه
للبحث عن ناجين
وفي شمال غربي سوريا فادى الدفاع المدني
السوري باصابه 190 شخصا جراء الزلزلين في
هاتاي واضاف ان اغلب الاصابات وقعت بسبب
سقوط حجاره او القفز من الابنيه المرتفعه
والتدافع وانهيار بنائين متصدعين غير
ماهولين ومئذنه مسجد في جنديرس الشماليه
حلب كمنهارت جدران وشرف منازل في عده مدن
وبلدات فري في حلب
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن خلال زيارته
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه انه سيتم الاعلان
في وقت لاحق هذا الاسبوع عن عقوبات اضافيه
ضد نخب وشركات روسيه واضاف بعيدا ان
واشنطن ستقدم مساعدات عسكريه جديده بقيمه
500 مليون دولار وان واشنطن ستوفر ايضا
المزيد من الذخيره لانظمه صواريخ المدفعيه
المتنقله لاوكرانيا من جهته يعتبر الرئيس
هو الاوكراني
اشاره دعم قوي لبلاده من جهه اخرى قالت
روسيا ان الزياره تمت بعد حصول واشنطن على
الضمانات الامنيه في المقابل قلل البيت
الابيض من التنسيق كان لتفادي اي سوء
تقدير قد يؤدي لصراع مباشر على حد تعبيره
حضر وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الصين من تزويد روسيا بالسلاح في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا وقلينا بلاده تراقب ذلك عن كتب
وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه ردا على تصريحات
الامريكيه بشان دراسه الصين تقديم اسلحه
لروسيا من الولايات المتحده هي من ترسل
الاسلحه الى ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا
واضافت الخارجيه ان واشنطن ليست في وضع
يسمح لها باخبار الصين ما يجب ان تفعله
وان موقف بيجين تجاه اوكرانيا واضح وقائم
على دعم محادثات السلام
اتهمت حركه النهضه في تونس مواصفاته بسلطه
الانقلاب بالزج بالقضاء والمؤسسات الامنيه
في السياسه جاء ذلك بعد استدعاء جديد
لرئيسها راشد الغنوشي لاستجوابه واضاف
عماد الخمري الناطق باسم الحركه ان قضيه
استدعاء الغنوشي تفتقد للجديه التي تستوجب
دعوته للتحقيق
وقد دعا الاتحاد التونسي للشغل الى ما
وصفها تعبئه العامه في مواجهه السلطه واقل
المتحدث باسم الاتحاد سامي الطاهرين
الاتحاد سيضطر الى تفعيل مبادره الحوار مع
الاحزاب السياسيه اذا رفضها الرئيس قيس
سعيد
اشكركم على متابعتي هذا الموجز
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]